what we can do is to pull the tissue
out like that
or also to squeeze the single testicles
a little bit like that
or also we can take it like that so kind
of make a ring around the base
and then tickle the underside like that
so these are just some of the strokes as
many more
[Music]
i see individual clients and couples
usually they want to learn how to
communicate better about pleasure
and or they come with very specific
sexual issues that they would like to
overcome
so in my sessions we can actually have
one way intimate touch
so i would wear gloves for any intimate
touch and i would stay fully closed
but they can be naked and so we explore
that in the session which makes the
sessions really effective
are there any cases that you're
particularly proud of
my name is 30 some who was married
and who had this issue all his life
really of wanting to last longer and not
really lasting as long as he wanted to
um and also um he had an issue with
particular sexual turn-ons that he
didn't want to share with his partner
and so there was a lot of shame involved
and so in the session we could talk that
through
these specific turn-ons and so um
the shame was was just solved like that
and we also explored an anal pleasure
because the penis actually corresponds
um to
clitoris in women and so if men only go
for penile pleasure
that's like a woman only having literal
orgasm orgasms
so we involved the prostate and we
involved the anus as well that was
completely new for him
and so that also made him last longer
because it's a more
wholesome arousal and also involving the
prostate but also the entire body so now
he could make love with his wife for up
to 40 minutes and so that was a great
success
something that's really a new phenomenon
is that
women are not happy with vulva labiaplus
d is on the rise
by about 30 to 40 percent
every year and it is very young
teenagers
who seek that because they don't think
that their vulva is acceptable so the
vulva is the outside part
here and the vagina is the inside part
but
often colloquially people call this a
vagina the vulva comes in in a huge
variety so even more variety than
penises actually
because the inner so either the outer
lips are really quite close
with this kind of barbie look like that
or the inner lips can stick out and
sometimes they are symmetrical
and sometimes they are quite fine and
sometimes they are a little bit fleshy
the g-spot sits on the ventral side here
and so in order to find it what you may
want to do is um
to insert a finger there is usually
g-spot tissue
which is called the g ridge from the
vaginal opening
and so it's not just the g-spot but the
g-spot is like when you insert a finger
and then you go around the corner and
that's the actual spot when we go to the
actual vagina
um first of all i would recommend to do
some raindrops maybe on the
on the womb area that's quite nice and
then what's also nice is to first of all
hold the pubic bone and to have the
other hand on the heart
like that and then from there what we
can do is first of all i call them [__]
strokes
and so um to just like take the hand
with with a lot of
loop or saliva just like stroke like
this
and then we can actually pick the entire
vulva up like that and squeeze a little
bit that's often quite nice
and then we can explore the groups so
there's grooves like between the outer
lips and the inner lips
and for an actual inside stroke
what i would recommend is to have um
one finger on the g-spot and um the
other hand the other
the thumb here on the side of the
clitoris so what's often quite sensitive
is the two o'clock here
when as if this was a clock face and him
to squeeze a little bit
like that and so it's this kind of
pincer movement
and also one finger can sit on the anus
that is quite nice and higher levels of
arousal
this is called holding the universe
what common misconceptions do men have
about the vagina
men are more happy than women um if they
are touched intimately um
quite soon in an intimate encounter for
for women it's the opposite so women
need to feel safe to open up
and so it's this misunderstanding
between
genders that men think okay they need to
find the clitoris first of all
but actually no they need to make the
woman feel safe
and what is the common misconception
women have about the penis
often men tell me that the women
handle the penis quite rough but it's a
it's a very
sensitive organ really and there are so
many things that we can do with the
penis
and it's not just that we need to have
an erect penis to deal with
and so there are also strokes for a
flaccid penis and that can feel very
nice as well
and so what you can do with a flaccid
penis is um you need a lot of lube
which can be either saliva or a proper
loop
and i would suggest to kind of like move
the penis around
and you can stroke it out to different
directions
what you can also do is and i can
demonstrate that with this more erect
penis
you can do that like that depending on
the size or you can do it like that
and you move the tip around so when it's
flaccid that's actually quite nice
like that and then there's some they all
have very funny names these
strokes there's some something that's
called lemon squeezer where you come
from the top
and you let the glands sit in the palm
of the hand
and then there's a kind of turning
movement and then taking it off again
or you can also do a go all the way to
the base which is the same way
and again turning around and then off
again
turning around what you can also do is
like
go along the underside of the penis
and press with the thumbs along the mid
line here
what is often quite nice is to stimulate
the frenulum here
the other thing is to engage the
testicles and so often that's where
women don't know that much about they
are a bit afraid
to touch the testicles to hurt them and
so what we can do
is to pull the tissue out like that
or also to squeeze the single testicles
a little bit like that
or also we can take it like that so kind
of make a ring around the base
and then tickle the underside like that
so these are just some of the strokes as
many more
we don't live in a very pleasure focused
society love making and
being intimate with our partners is
something hugely important
and the paradigm needs to change there
people make love at the end of the day
when everything else is done
that means they are tired uh especially
like if they have children on top of
that and full-time jobs
and um sex is not good quality sex
i encourage people to schedule physical
dates
with each other and to actually plan
those
um so maybe even a sexting before
so that um each can contribute their
ideas
um to uh plan that date
and um to make it more interesting and
also to
um cultivate their erotic creativity
often people tell me things that they've
never never told anybody
before because some sexuality is such an
intimate
um such an intimate issue and it's often
the
make or break issue in in people's lives
you